you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I'm going to play now a 15-2
game so let's see what we get here okay
that's Sicilian let's go with tonight f3
and what will black do e 6 d 6 9 c 6 e 6
it is ok hmm should I go with D 4 or not
I may want to experiment with something
else turn this into a Kings Indian
attack um let's try for that I'm kind of
shifting gears now so yeah let's go for
these universal moves now night on B - D
- G 3 bishop - G - only only at this
point I don't have to do this this is
this is played only when this move is
played and there's the threat to
exchange Queens so I'm going to hold off
on declaring my Knights intentions let's
get in G 3 let's see what black does a
big decision with the deep on to go one
or two squares black could consider
moving this pawn again okay so they're
not so quick to give ground well they're
not so quick to let's say give up the e5
square they're seeking control over a
five only the idea is with the Kings
Indian attack is to establish upon an e5
and then go after the black Kings throat
so d6 already takes some
steps to stop this advance so pretty
much locked into playing Bishop g2 so
let's get that in I'll probably go with
Kings side castle next and still retain
some flexibility with my queen Knight so
let's see and just Castle right away
yeah let's just Castle there's a dog
going crazy in the background I don't
know if you could hear it
turn up the volume maybe you could hear
that wild dog alright alright perfect
timing man perfect timing
you weren't darn you you weren't barking
just before I started this recording but
right now is the perfect time it's not
the crazy beagle though Luca what to do
here besides talk about the barking Doug
uh-huh
rook to e1 seems useful hmm
where do I want to go with my queen
Knight not sure you know rook to e1
castles I'm gonna have to make a
decision at some point with my queen
Knight my C pawn I mean what do I want
to think about doing something like c 3
and d 4 not so sure about that what
about this guy maybe something like this
a knight on c3 and Bishop here maybe I
already know my queen Knights place
maybe I go at night c3 and even
considered going into like a delay to
open Sicilian in a way where eventually
I do go ahead and play d4 and we have a
C and D pawn exchange I think I know my
queen Knights place hmm yeah let's get
him there he
I think that this is some idea doesn't
doesn't seem right teams it seems to
slow I should say and yeah even if I if
I did go forward with this III in d4
there's always the follow up of takes
takes d5 or maybe d5 right away and
looking to anchor in the night on the
square so I'm giving some consideration
to Bishop 2f form to provoke some
weakness I'd like to play this advance
and kind of disrupt this pandu well I
know it's a pond duel that setback some
so what we might identify as a small
pond Center but this is a desirable move
because it opens up this dog you know
and I'd like this night to be able to
move I wouldn't mind seeing my king
Knight exchange for their Queen night
just so he's unmasked on Bishop f4 e 5
maybe then I could look to play in the
white squares so for example Bishop g5
maybe I'm alright with giving up my dark
square Bishop and then focusing on here
maybe even doing some kind of a knight
dance into this square it would be a
hole as soon as this pawn pushes so I'm
leaning towards Bishop f4 yeah I'm
leaning towards that okay let's give it
a shot don't know if it's the correct
idea about we're gonna pull the trigger
on it we're gonna try something just
under 10 already he 5 will they allow
this we're going to see
well first see this is this is a reason
I was pointing out earlier rook to e1 I
don't know that this rook knows its
place just yet if I can be assured that
the e-file becomes half-open only then
will I play rook to e1 or consider it
more but until that time comes I think
it's best that he stays put it may so
happen that when this for winter if this
is played the direction to then go in is
maybe even for an F pawn push F to F for
striking at e5 in which case the rook is
ideally placed to support this advance
so the short summer here is I'm waiting
on making a rook move until I am certain
that a file is opened or half opened so
what are they going to do ee v are they
going to work more to try and get their
Queen Bishop okay so I did say Bishop g5
and then focusing on this square here
but mm maybe not even well let's go here
to start let's see if they're gonna go
in for this it would be a weakening move
okay they're gunning straight for this
I'm gonna put a halt to that make them
work a little bit harder bait a4 is
basically saying if you are to establish
a pawn on d5 you will have have to first
help my rook hmm I could take the knight
and jump right in I think that this
might have been a bit accurate a bit
inaccurate to be shooting for this b5
move takes here Knight d5 right away and
you know it's only temporary that I'm
down the bishop pair because at just you
know in just a moment I could regain it
by taking hmm
my idea here I think is to take
recapture 95b five chop chop is to then
make a night move like Knight d2 which
paves the way for f4 hmm what's another
move to consider what's another plan to
maybe shoot for I don't know if it would
be good for me if I allow you know if
Knight d5 can be met with Bishop takes
Knight like if I'm not shooting for this
right away if I go for this and I may
want to go for this and you know only
after h6 only after there's a question
put to my Bishop what I capture that
would save a move over the line I'm
considering right now of taking without
being provoked Knight d2 however Bishop
e6 and I don't know Bishop takes Bishop
takes Knight here Bishop takes Knight
pawn takes how are things looking in
that position it'd be an office of color
Bishop position
this Knight would have to find a new
home and I think he would actually find
it a bit uncomfortable to do that maybe
I'm okay if I see Bishop e6 and replied
of 92 mm-hmm let's go for this right
away
yeah and got to make a move quit trying
to be a perfectionist it's not happening
you're a long way off
you're a long way off and they d2 the
old you know repositioning here I'd like
to get this in right away actually
Bishop on Bishop e6 I'm just saying now
I could jump right into c4 III and then
here you know so I really don't have any
fear Bishop e6 I'm also at this move
preventing d5 altogether even if it was
an idea it's definitely not now okay so
I can't jump in here just yet this
Knights unprotected don't really think I
could take advantage of that though take
the knight now is there any other useful
move to get in hmm he's gonna get kicked
soon I want to be able to play here h3
is that useful if before I take on takes
Knight Bishop takes Bishop on the Queen
and then I recapture I'd like to see
them do this move because they give up
c4
I think h3 is useful let's get one more
useful move in yeah and on Bishop here
I'm still fine with the capture and then
jumping into d5 let's see will they play
b4
on b4 and pretty much locked into taking
um this is the third time now I'm
playing against this guy but I believe
the first time it's a standard game
could be wrong good opponent here L M
stands for Lea chess master
if you're wondering okay let's see what
they come up with I'm thinking it's
going to be B for Bishop e6 I'm fine
with seeing h6 so really a position oh
that's a move I did not consider huh
maybe I don't exchange darks where
bishops know I don't want to help you to
develop Bishop takes Bishop the night I
think recaptures and I want to jump in
here yeah also I have this as an idea so
he's under its they underdeveloped with
that move taking here I'm helping them
to develop well I don't know about that
maybe I could have done that I think
both are fine this is all over more
direct
I made that move pretty quick that
decision pretty quick let's see I have a
nice open file here for the rook at some
point maybe he can have something to say
along the seventh rank who knows for
when or if the file opens up this is an
issue I think I jump right in right now
unlike d5 eat d4 is not a whole these
corresponding squares f4
things are getting pretty serious here
yeah maybe I play f4 first let's give it
a shot it's a pretty natural pawn break
huh if they're not careful maybe I play
out five if they play fi of himself
they're vulnerable on this diagonal
mm-hmm
I should be making a mental note to
myself that I'm also vulnerable with my
F pawn advance both the diagonal and
rank you know the king is the king is
finding it a bit more uncomfortable when
that F pawn moves diagonal pressure it's
weakened on the diagonal and also the
rank not as cosy home anymore when he's
on h2 he starts to become that much more
important to hang on to it's already
important as soon as g3 is played that
your LightSquared Bishop is maintained
he's going to be an important defender
for my Kings side so they're allowing
this advance I feel like I want to
address this Knight address this Knight
position right away huh I'm tempted to
like do this and push if I play here I
think Bishop g5 is a strong reply and
then I have to start worrying about the
Queen and the knight I want to take care
of this knight in my position right away
so 95 c3 giving up giving him a kick
however here takes pawn taste there's
Knight f5 when he's hit
maybe then actually g4 first I could
play g4 yes I think I'm leaning more
towards this now g4 to stop f5 well
things are getting real sharp now hmm f5
maybe I go what know if I've still that
Bishop g5 is a great bother hmm don't
watch out they might play a 5 ok
we're gonna give this a shot I'm a bit
nervous about it though yeah I'm a bit
nervous about this g4 move well they
just give my knight a kick we're gonna
see I'm a bit nervous of b4 here Knight
takes pawn takes f5 don't know how
things are gonna work out from there oh
you know what here's another thing if
here takes pawn takes I have a new
square for my knight 94 could be strong
yeah this is this is getting very very
sharp mm-hmm
let's see what black does to be patient
in these positions try and squeeze as
much out of the position as possible I'm
not so quick to jump in I'd really like
to first cb4 I want them to invest some
time tempo to chasing my knight to this
square he's certainly eyeing up has been
eyeing up for some time on a Bishop d7
move I think this starts to make it life
a little bit uncomfortable for black
pressure on the rook and the rook is
tied down he cannot contest the a file
I'd be fine seeing this on a good day
I'd like to have some kind of a pawn
fixed on that f6 square and okay they're
just going in for the capture okay
Bishop takes Knight as an idea but now
let's take what the rook excuse me take
with the bishop taking with the rook
allows this pressure on d6 if Bishop g5
is played can I just drop back Bishop
here is a Czech king each one yikes I'm
gonna challenge this night soon I don't
know if I want to play to d5 anymore
he's not such a good piece maybe it's
more important if b4 I actually go to e2
hmm give up on this idea of night okay
preserve the dark square bishop soar not
I think I need to and where should he go
let's go here Bishop takes Knight Queen
takes no tricky Knight moves yeah I'd
like to see b4 hmm B 4 B 3 B 4 a knight
move b3 some combination of takes b3
pawn push Knight c2 is only hitting one
piece there are certain scenarios where
the pawn can come down here ideally I'd
like to push not capture because it
gives the rook play so if the pawn is on
b3 I want to be able to play c3 then
there's a pivot square and c2 but
nothing
well the rook is hit and maybe there's
even something like this although my
queen at that stage would be on d2 I'm
looking at something like Bishop takes
Knight Queen takes b4
a night move and then here okay Bishop
move so that it feels like I have a
moment to breathe after that move and
that night needs to be challenged like
this you know let's let's get rid of
this piece that's in my position Bishop
you give a check I'm not sure which is
better it feels like king h2 moving up
the board some securing h3 to be a
little bit mindful of an h5 strike I
have some pawns here clearly
overextended black still has a much more
compact King side pawn structure so to
be on the lookout for this it's a nice
way to soften up my King side position
taking like this to win upon weaken my
King position further it feels like this
is this is a fine move certainly would
be one that's on my candidate list
playing as black I could maybe consider
do I have the time for it I don't know
maybe avoid this Knight exchange and
then kick him away and maybe he has to
find a new home right now this this
isn't a happy piece on c6 hmm it's a
tight game that's like an intense Bishop
e3 check King h2 I'd be happy to see
either capture here I know my reply Wow
okay so actually Knight f4 but then b4
8f for I think avoid the night exchange
place III if I play see three Knight
takes Queen takes this is hitting hmm
maybe night here and then here Wow let's
go for Knight f4 it's a big moment I
think they have to play b4 right now to
meet c3 would takes and the rook comes
to life and there's pivot squares on b3
however you know I could take this guy
out and another thing is be for c3 takes
takes Knight b5 the c3 spawn hit twice
defended 0 so maybe I have to disrupt
the bishops position before I consider
kicking the knight out of my position
here maybe I am not able to play c3 and
reply to be far this is unprotected
indirectly hit Knight h5 is something
where are there unprotected pieces this
is a very yeah it's really wild position
well not too wild but at any moment okay
that's a move I did not fear get that
night out of my position
and yeah this is where black I think is
going wrong now
I think when we look back because now
look at I get to do this open position
I'd really like to see Bishop takes
Knight on b4 well I mean I could
eliminate this guy I'm threatening to
win both bishops would the knight pair
let's say have good homes to operate on
I don't know let's see how they react
we're kind of balancing out here on the
clock they have about a minute advantage
got that increment though given time
maybe I expand with D form I have enough
support for it suppose they avoid the
exchange would I go with d4 maybe oh
they're just giving up the dark square
bishop like that I don't think I want to
take because of this and the pressure
maybe I should start putting pressure on
my opponent on the clock some you know
what let's let's rock them back I have
pieces in better position yeah
let's establish a pawn duo in the center
do so with tempo okay let's see where
the night's gonna go Knight here 9 th 5
that has to be pretty annoying huh
yeah so they're getting pushed back
Knight f6 Knight h5 things are turning
eyes have to stay peeled though okay
they're just cashing out right away
striking I think this 1 2 3 I have 3
supporters where do I want to keep my
dark square bishop
okay Queen b6 is an idea
I think Bishop here actually yeah just
take taking preventive measures against
some potential pin this was my natural
well you know what that wasn't working
because I could take here
okay g3 was better I'm currently
threatening a fork d5 okay let's take
like this yes still that open a file I
have an open F file my rooks are better
the networks doing trying to do a piece
by piece assessment where they try and
stop d5 by playing d5 this nights
unprotected let's keep this in mind
Bishop rook Queen tempies any uh many
different attacking moves against this
night okay I have an idea of this now
right feels like a good square the Queen
isn't guarding that right now who mm-hm
can't even consider d5 and then Knight
here
eyeing up c6 and f5 don't know that I
want to give up this square though hmm
a knight on a five man he's enormous a
knight on f5 you can't work you can't
fight against a night on f5 he's a
monster
also there without a dark square bishop
so if g6 to kick out night out of the f5
square h6 Bishop h6 Knight g6 Knight f5
Knight h4 maybe Bishop back maybe not
maybe I'm ok with giving up my life
square bishop and there's something
direct very concrete here Knight takes
pawn takes I get in f6 that has to be
good if I could make this g7 pawn flinch
hmm 96 nine f5 okay I feel like I have
some serious attack going on now
I'm not taking taking allows this night
in excellent square I'm I'm certainly
liking my decision with my bishop now
okay I think he still goes straight in
there is there a reason to not play that
right away no not that I could see also
I have an eye on the clock so oh yeah he
just better make a move Knight takes
pawn takes f6 he's not playing he's not
playing the Queen is not playing until
the knight moves and well where is he
gonna go
tough spot mm-hmm okay
I have Knight d6 okay let's go go Queen
d2
this might already be an idea Bishop h6
pawn takes Queen takes looking for mate
there let's let's turn your my attention
here to the F file something's going to
there's there should be some something
dangerous happening against the black
King okay to f1 on night here Bishop g5
is game over the fork it's one of the
ideas behind Queen d2 doesn't allow this
Knight h4 move this is one square that
there is some coordination between the
black pieces in the Y position so I
think they're taking measures okay let's
maybe try and provoke a weakness let's
just see how they react to that I got to
throw some punches stopping Knight d6
with that Knight move maybe here and
here yeah let's do it
that night position where is he gonna go
if he's challenged h6 taking keeping
this tonight here okay take with the
pawn although my rooks look pretty good
too
let's go here let's do that oh and
dropping upon why did I do that they
missed it let's just go here defend d4 I
have this I haven't given up on this
move let's keep pushing crack like that
I should have played f6 sooner huh
bishop pair versus knight pair don't
want to do this so quick less than 20
for my opponent okay I don't know let's
go here I'm not sure my queen could do
better
mm-hmm didn't want to do it okay
floundering some let's take that pawn
you pawn grab are you where's that night
going okay kill that night hmm pile up
on the G file another night I could take
him out
let's go here let's defend that pawn
bishop here double on the G file finally
no my rook is pinned I could have played
this okay tripled up Bishop takes Knight
mm-hmm just make the move okay actually
I could do this right I could have taken
the bishop then that last move now I got
it I had on the previous move as soon as
the Queen played here
let's take smashing through now who they
resigned that was tense man whoo all
right that was tense yeah let's go let's
go through this one bringing up the
analysis board oh okay
yeah well hang on for one moment before
I even look at the computer evaluation I
think that well there'll be hmm
different suggestions of course before
we get to this point here but I felt
like things really turned in this
position right here Bishop here I think
is where black really started to go
wrong because these next moves are me
moving forward and my opponent's replies
are what are they having to do they're
they have to demote their pieces they're
running in Reverse there mmm under
developing
see three robbed the night of that
square he goes in reverse I move forward
Knight f3 threatening to grab the bishop
pair well
he's avoiding you know one of the one of
the bishop captures d4 again moving
forward so there's some concessions now
position has opened up I'm playing with
the bishop pair and I have a nice Center
now so I think that there's certainly an
improvement right here okay they're
calling for a knight there right now now
that the computer has this analysis but
yeah this there's certainly an
improvement on this move and I'm sure
many many other points throughout the
game for both of us but uh let's turn on
the engine and let's just get a feel for
how the game went okay um I'm satisfied
I I expected a little bit of a drop off
at some stage expected black to be
better at some point like significantly
at some stage but I guess there weren't
any serious errors so let's see I need
to go in through here and I've already
made some pointers on this uh d6 move if
you go in for d5 there's there's d5 and
then possibilities for I a strong King
side attack so Bishop f4 is it all right
with Bishop f4 it's fine with Bishop f4
now Bishop g5 wants to take the knight
right away a3 what's the story with that
I'm not really sure see hey three am I
going to be able to figure out the idea
suppose they're okay yeah a3 I'm not
sure about
three a-four is more natural or
human-like okay 92 I'll issue at 92
takes takes h3 yeah just trying to be
extra patient here I'm trying to get as
much out of the position as I can I
don't want I want I wanted to see this I
wanted some time to be invested before I
actually commit Bishop takes Knight h3
is useful Knight B for seems awkward
when you do all these prep moves a6 rook
b8 b5 seems before but Knight v4 is an
interesting way to guard the d5 square
okay that's cool right there it's still
even wants to go in for an exchange
Bishop e3 still holding is a pretty even
position here now h4 rook e1 popping up
f4 I guess is an okay move g4 MS things
started to get it I started become a bit
concerned around here takes bishop takes
you know this is where there's so many
different move choices you know I'm not
throwing any great punch at black they
have what we might call a free move you
know look at the position try and come
up with some plan there's I'm not I it's
my last move I'm not giving any great
direction to my opponent so they have a
free hand to come up with something 96
mm-hmm what was I concerned about right
around here right around this point
instead of g4 this is what I did not
like and I'm glad I didn't do it yeah
cuz Knight takes and look at this Knight
I'm exchanging this Knight that's on you
know a square where how many options
does he have his best best-case scenario
is that he has six options
and I want to allow him to exchange
himself off so easily so I want to I
want to play against his poor position
so if I did okay now it's pointing out
ninety-two if I did go with this
this was my concern yes Knight f5 even
you know when I do try and kick the
night it's this f5 Square and well they
even want to go here right away
and apparently not maintain my dark
square bishop I offer to do this takes
here and who look at these squares to
split pawns on my Kings side homes for
the black pieces yes this is it this is
an important structure to you need to
accurately assess that type of a
structure and that was just that would
just be awful
g4 certainly watches out for that night
of five move where if to just make it
past move night here ninety five is now
much different takes takes there isn't
night f5 but I still had my concerns
here because of the move f5 okay I guess
that's not quite working out but takes
first here and then b4 okay I guess
that's to give a new square for the
night he's running low on squares with
this pawn here but uh you know hope to
be careful of this the night stepping
foot on f5 it's a very disruptive piece
so okay glad I didn't go with Knight d5
I played g4 it likes nighty to better g4
I guess is alright takes takes Bishop g5
I avoid the exchange I don't think that
this amounts to anything Bishop e3 King
h1 I think I would have played here
not too much of a difference and then
look to challenge this night soon I have
a grip over these two pawn breaking
moves f5 d5 better Brooks okay with
Bishop e6 right there still if this
check occurs was king h1 any issues with
King h2 no okay they didn't do that they
played Bishop f6 and it does like Knight
to f4 Knight f4 and this is where I was
thinking b4 Bishop e5 and this is where
there's the change that I thought there
was I thought there would be
whit's Bishop to e5 I know it's just
slight but this has been a really tight
game that gets multiplied sore - 0.3
throughout up to this point here where
we move 20 software to go from even to
0.5 that's there's already some
adjustment to be made there it likes
knight c6 but I wondered during the game
about b4 b4 is also another move I
pointed out that if c3 there's takes
takes Knight b5 and what am i doing
about two pieces hitting this square
it's difficult likes black here close to
a pawn so he's not so easily kicked with
the b4 move in before it would have been
better than this okay they went with
that and now things are really turning 9
f3 d4 it's just a growing advantage from
here Bishop g3 I went to e3 yeah this
was a this was my fear but it isn't
working I thought because I would have
this
although maybe not some tricky stuff
here or take either rook and there's
night takes tonight it's complicated to
say the least so I went to e3 just
anticipating some potential pressure
here this is my x-factor bishop I wants
to push right away I'd like just
maintaining my center focus on improving
my night position some already there's
some tricks in mind with Bishop here if
I'm just to make a passing move I think
this is a move it is it's gotta be pawn
takes Queen takes threatening mate here
even f6 Queen g7 ideas so these ideas
you know your black is without their
dark square bishop so playing against
the dark squares a super night pressure
on a dark square Bishop and Queen
focused on the dark squares should
really raise your tension should really
be focused on the dark squares if that's
the case if you're lacking a dark square
Bishop extra extra care is needed for
sure just right with the doubling of the
rooks and I'm sure there's plenty of
stuff missed from this point on much
cleaner approach it likes what f6 right
away yeah they didn't take on their five
but I guess it's still winning at this
point here they could take on the five
it's still winning it's Queen there I
don't know if I would have done that
Queen B five I guess other stuff wins
too huh Queen B four snake doesn't have
a square King here and then push right
there yeah what do we have just a wide
open position the bishop pair okay well
they didn't they didn't grab on f5 those
two
around to advantage just did not want to
fall for any little tricks here yeah and
it was never really slipped away I could
have taken that night a little bit
sooner on h6 you know you know this is
where we're just blitzing it out you
know easy to make a mistake here and
yeah at that point I captured and this
is even leading to me rook takes Queen
here push
yikes what's the trick here Queen there
Oh check and then me clearing out that
g7 square okay well interesting game
very tough fight one of the more
difficult standard games I've I've
played yeah very good game as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and as
usual I hope you got something out of it
that's all for now take care bye
you